my name is Nate renello and I am a hook
trimmer I'm going to show you how I
remove rocks and screws from cow speed
I trim primarily dairy cows on a typical
day I'll trim anywhere from 40 to 50
cows so you're talking 160 to 200 feet
depending on the day and the number of
cows that the farmer has to trim that
day
the shoot that we put the cow in is used
to keep her in one place basically so
she's not walking around helps us to
lift the feet up safely and work on them
without removing them
she can still move but it just gives us
a safer working environment to run our
Grinders and our knives we're dealing
with really sharp tools and so we want
to try to keep that foot as motionless
as possible while we work on it
so what we're looking at here is the cow
that has stepped on a screw and at this
point I'm not really sure how deep this
screw is embedded so that's what I kind
of have to investigate is their pain
here is this a long screw that's all the
way through that hoof capsule and into
the aquarium or is it just a surface
problem
for the basic anatomy of the college
hoof you've got that the outer structure
which is what everyone sees that's the
hoof capsule the hard part that they
walk on but right underneath that is a
layer called the corium on the sole of
the foot that's what produces the sole
of the foot the very bottom of the foot
what I'm trying to do is actually to
trim the foot and get the angles in the
foot back to their normal State that's
what makes them comfortable so just like
in people if we wear uncomfortable shoes
that have flat soles you can feel that
in your feet almost immediately you can
feel that discomfort same thing with a
cow
so when I find something like this the
first thing that I do is I try to remove
the debris from around it and I'm using
my hoof knife here and what I'm doing is
trying to get a hold of that screw and
trying to see if it's an entire screw
how firmly embedded it is in the foot
and if I can actually remove it with the
hook of my hoof knife so at this point
I'm going to use a pliers to pull this
screw out and the reason I did that is
it was too firmly embedded to remove
with my hoof knife I don't want to apply
downward pressure because at this point
I'm not sure if this is punctured
through and you can see it's about three
quarters of an inch left of this screw
it's a fairly sizable screw definitely
something that would cause damage if it
had gone all the way through I don't
think it has based on what's left the
only thing would be is if there was some
left inside that foot and that we'll
have to figure out as we keep going air
so what I use to trim the cow's hoof is
actually a four and a half inch angle
grinder and it's got a specifically
designed cutting head on it that shaves
away the hoof as I trim so what I'm
doing here is just reducing this hoof
down to creating the natural foot angles
that she needs
obviously you can't do as much finesse
work with a grinder as you can with a
knife so anything that takes a lot of
finesse or where you have to be real
careful about touching things that's
when I'm gonna use the knife because I
can be much more accurate with it as far
as creating a uniform sole I can do a
better job with this grinder than I can
with a knife
one of the most common questions I get
is does this process hurt the cow and
trimming clubs is just like us trimming
our fingernails it doesn't there's no
pain in the nail whatsoever no pain in
the hoof it's the internal structures of
the foot that have feeling and we try to
avoid those when we're trimming as much
as possible
cow's foods are very similar in makeup
as human fingernails made of keratin the
only difference is they walk on those
the outer hoof layer doesn't have any
feeling so I can clean up that pretty
safely without causing any discomfort
it's the inner structures of the foot
that I'm concerned about where that
screw may have poked through to that's
where it would be sensitive and when I
get to those points that's from much
more hesitant as far as using my knife
that black dot that you see is a
Telltale sign of a puncture from
something metal and basically what
you're looking at there is what I
believe anyway to be oxidation from the
steel in the screw itself and this is
common when you see a puncture from a
nail or a screw like this you'll have a
nice Perfect Circle right around where
that puncture was
so I'm going to continue to track down
this black spot all the way until it
disappears or until I get to corium if
it gets to that corium layer I know
there's likely going to be an infection
that we'll have to deal with however I'm
just going to keep working slowly
removing layers of this to make sure
that there is no problem basically I
know that this hoof layer is going to be
about a half of an inch thick so I can
tell how deep I'm going and how much
further I have to go based on that and
the consistency will also change it'll
get softer so I'll be able to tell when
I'm getting close to that aquarium layer
but luckily for this girl the screw did
not puncture all the way through to the
corium so this is just was just caught
in her soul
so picking up this cow's foot I can see
there's a hole there and when I'm
working with my hoof knife I can feel
individual stones in this hole what
happens is cows when they go from the
outside environment to up onto concrete
those rocks can get embedded into that
Sole and over time they can actually
work their way all the way through and
puncture as well she is showing signs of
discomfort with this foot so that's what
I suspect has happened when I discover
all these rocks in here
there's no real good way to get the
stones out without just simply picking
them out with my hoof knife so that's
what I'm doing here I'm scraping away
trying to pull out as many of these
rocks as I can before I start to work on
them
[Music]
you might think that larger Stones would
be a bigger problem but in actuality
it's the smaller stones that have the
the ability to embed in the foot you may
get a larger Stone embedded in the very
in the very surface of the sole but it's
hard to drive a large Stone through the
soul itself it's these smaller stones
that have the opportunity to find small
cracks in the white line and in that
sole to and be able to puncture through
the aquarium
you have to realize that a cow weighs
anywhere from 1200 pounds a thousand
pounds let's say a thousand pounds up to
sixteen hundred pounds so you're looking
at 250 to 400 pounds per foot so if you
have some Stones some small rocks in
that and they step onto concrete you can
see how that would penetrate and drive
right into that soul
the consistency of a cow's foot is
similar to a hard rubber tire on a car
it doesn't take much for all of that
weight to press those rocks in there and
then over time continually putting
pressure on those can drive them deeper
and deeper into that sole
the spray I'm using is called
chlorhexidine it's an antiseptic I'm
using that to not only irrigate the foot
and try to clean out any of the debris
that's in there but also disinfect
because this has punctured through the
aquarium there's a bit of infection
starting to set in
it's not only that the the rocks that
can cause the problem here what has
happened is we have small areas of
Separation around that those rocks have
caused due to the cows natural response
of trying to release that soul to try to
heal this this problem up so that loose
layer of horn needs to be removed as
well those small little Jagged edges so
that's what I'm trying to clean up but
the idea is to try to remove as much of
that as you can safely so you don't get
debris and stuff packed in there and and
reinfect the area later foreign
[Music]
the grinder I use to do the majority of
the shaping of the foot in this case I
use it also to prepare that other claw
to apply a rubber block to it
what the rubber block does is elevates
that injured claw off the ground and
keeps her from walking on this damaged
one
I will often use a salicylic acid wrap
to treat these and what what that does
is it will kill any potential bacteria
specifically the bacteria that cause
digital dermatitis it's an infection
that cows can get if that infection sets
in it can actually keep this area open
and prevent that corium layer from
producing the hard outer layer so it'll
remain open so what the salicylic acid
does is it kills that bacteria and it
will help Slough away any of the dead
skin and stuff in there
foreign
went well we were able to remove all of
the rocks from this and get it elevated
so she should have no problems healing
this up
in natural environments they will
actually shed on their own they wouldn't
need trimming from humans because the
hoof has got a natural hydration level
as it starts to dry out it'll flake away
and fall off the foot on farms they
don't get that natural shedding process
so the hoof on the bottom of the foot
stays hydrated all the time so it
doesn't fall away and that's why we trim
them to recreate the natural angles that
they're supposed to be now when it comes
to lesions and things like that they
would heal themselves over time as well
but it just takes much longer to do that
so by a process that would normally take
two to three months maybe to heal we can
make heal in week to 10 days we can
provide Comfort almost immediately when
we trim them so that's why we do that